this is lucy james reading for reviewer
mike epstein
in its opening moments astros playroom
literally describes itself as a tutorial
specifically it explains that the
playroom's light and light-hearted
platforming levels
are a means of showing off the special
features of the playstation 5's new dual
sense controller
some like the adaptive triggers haptic
feedback
and built-in microphone are new others
like the touchpad and the gyroscope
are not but they all distinguish the
dual sense from its xbox and nintendo
based counterparts
while astros playroom absolutely goes
out of its way to offer clever proof of
the ps5's potential
like the dual sensor's new tricks the
improved visuals and the quick load
times
the disembodied text at the start of the
game sells astro short
playroom is an incredibly charming jaunt
through a playstation inspired digital
theme park
ensuring that your first hop skip and
jump of the ps5 era
is holy unequivocally joyful
[Music]
astros world the literal playroom is a
cartoon fantasy style
interpretation of the playstation 5. the
game's four levels and hub world are all
named after the console's components
like gpu jungle and cooling springs
inside each
is a dream-like playstation playground
your typical platforming level locales
like beach
city and meadow are decorated with
computer chips and parts of playstations
past
woven into their fabric each one is
densely packed with fun little scenes
and
interactive set dressing astro's
adorable bot friends hang out
play games and cosplay as some of the
platform's iconic characters
making every adventure feel like a party
too
having the playstation hype train baked
into every nook and cranny of the world
could have felt overbearing but it's all
very endearing
the level design is more clever than
cloying and the bots are all very cute
and their happy vibes are surprisingly
contagious the playstation
references are tied to collectibles
which fill up an interactive museum
space called playstation labo
as you find puzzle pieces that turn into
playstation themed murals and giant
virtual models the space quickly turns
into a very concentrated nostalgia hit
for fans of playstation's history it
also gives you a place to use
all the coins you've been grabbing
there's a gacha machine in the back
that will sell you even more
collectibles
that gives you a reason to go but i
found this to be the rare game
where i actually wanted to survey the
collectibles after i found them
that's partially because i enjoyed
walking around and jumping on the giant
playstation memorabilia
but it's also because the space full of
bots playing with playstation gear
felt more engaging than a plane menu or
empty viewing space
they're also a wonderful showcase for
the playstation 5's enhanced visual and
technical performance
playing on a 4k tv with hdr 10 the
levels are bright
colorful and intricately detailed there
are tons of little bots running around
in the background foreground and
everywhere in between
the vast majority of which you can
interact with by jumping on or punching
them
between the bots enemies and moving
elements like platforms
running water and floating clouds the
world is full of life
and there are no meaningful loading
screens jumping from the hub area to one
of the levels triggers a short
transition sequence for a couple of
seconds
but it feels like a fluid part of the
game rather than a distraction
though simply going to astros playroom
and looking around is a pleasure
the platforming is nothing to sneeze at
astros jumps and punches
feel snappy and responsive as he makes
his way through the world
much of the platforming is simple yet
still challenging in spots
it helps that each level occasionally
branches into two paths
a simple direct path for new players and
a more challenging one for veterans
experienced players aren't going to have
much trouble even with the tougher
sections
but it'll push you to try each level
also has two sections where astro puts
on a special suit
that gives him a new means of getting
around each suit is made to highlight
one or more dual sense features
in one level there's the spring suit
which jumps after you pull the triggers
and let go
almost as if you are pushing down on an
actual spring
in another you become a giant ball
rolling around by swiping the touchpad
[Music]
the dual sensor's adaptive triggers
which can provide haptic feedback and
varying levels of resistance when you
pull them
get an especially bright spotlight the
resistance from the triggers combined
with the controller's new more nuanced
haptic feedback
can tell you lots of different things in
context like how much you've pulled back
the string of a bow
the building force of a spring-powered
jump or that a locked gacha arm
won't budge when you try and steal an
extra pull all of these sequences are
effective demonstrations of the dual
sense controller but not all of them
are actually fun a trigger powered
rocket ship effectively shows off the
potential for using trigger resistance
to give feedback on a vehicle's throttle
but it relies on careful boosting and
more importantly unwieldy motion
controls that feel frustratingly
inaccurate
compared to the responsive platforming
controls in fact
motion controls pop up in a couple of
these sequences and can have an uncanny
knack for making any kind of gameplay
more wonky
and unpleasant than it has to be there
are also fans scattered throughout the
level that require you to blow into the
dual sensor's built-in microphone
it's a neat but ultimately benign trick
in fact it's completely optional
if you mute the controller mic the fans
spin automatically
occasionally forced applications of the
dual sensors feature set
can hurt the game more than they help
the best and worst thing i can say about
astros playroom is that its role as a
demonstration
feels a bit wasteful it's a wondrous
little dream world
and i would have loved to spend more
time touring it but that in itself
is a tremendous achievement astros
playroom a game that makes no attempt to
hide the fact that it is an excuse to
show you what a gamepad can do
conjures a world that you will want to
see and explore
more than that it's surprisingly
delightful celebration of playstation
and its games
is a great way to kick off a console
[Music]
generation
you